歡迎收看趙華
我是趙華
我是艾倫
艾倫回來了
終於回來了
你知不知道現在出了多少亂子
你是說是台灣股市嗎
都很多啊
就是到底什麼樣的情況下
半夜四點會爬起來呢
你是說怎麼又面這件事情
我只有聯準會說
可能要升息的時候
我可能會跳起來
等一下半夜四點對我們財經人來說
是很重要的時間點
對呀基本上就是要嘛公布盤
或財報嘛
要嘛就聯準會
記者會講完了嘛
對不對 不然就是突然飛彈要射出來了嘛
大概就這樣
因為呢 半夜四點
唯有可能如果看到一些事情會傳遍給你
就是美股那時候收盤啊
對啊
如果發生嚴重的大事情的話
我們確實會起來上廁所的時候
稍微看一下盤面
不過呢 台股反彈到這個地方
我們這幾天是有點開始出現
那些橫盤整理
甚至有一點點小回落
這個是所謂要打腳嗎
這個問題非常的好
我們等一下用技術面向來看一下
但是到底為什麼事情就是這樣
在反彈的時候因為彈得很急
你不在的那個禮拜彈得很急
那就會覺得好像就一路不回頭了
可是就會永遠發生一些事情
讓這個彈稍微停住一下
那停住的同時我們到底往下走
要樂觀看還是要謹慎看
還是我就繼續放假
keypoint在你啊
對
我們來看一下
為什麼昨天台子夜盤
我想說不錯 早了快400點
請來看1.60點
看一下又是美伊的關係
所以現在美伊關係
還是會稍微影響到
美國的股市走勢
對 那尤其是可能反彈到這個階段
大家又覺得
有一些比較敏感的狀態出現
我覺得早到這裡
大家又要開始找一個理由
說要不要休息一下
事情有那麼簡單嗎
是的 沒有錯
我們來看一下
這個60天的和平談判期
快要已經借滿了
那雙方是沒有達成協議的
反而分歧是更深
所以大家會覺得說
這個美醫是不是又無果了
那無果就推動油價去做上漲
那主要還有一個原因
就是核母子海峽呢
基本上都
就運量不是很好
所以看起來還是有在封鎖的
那這些原因就油價會上漲
油價上漲剛好沒在直率也上漲
這個時候誰就要下跌
股價就要下跌
對 所以目前來說
這件事情影響到短線上的
一些股市上的總市
但其實昨天每股的半導體
是很強的
對啊 這個費半是漲了1.6%左右
那其他三指數是回落
什麼記憶體那一類還是很強
當然今天台灣股市
因為韓國昨天沒開盤
那今天韓國開盤了
開盤早上漲三巴很厲害
一看奇怪怎麼變跌的
台灣股市也變跌了
所以有一些壓力
那目前來說
這件事情就是恆股市海峽
到底該怎麼辦
那譚布隆
譚布隆就震盪囉
這兩個 這兩國走得很前面
他已經暗示你一件事了
要和平分手是不可能的
現在也是啊
三月就開始講了
我們財經也是有男女主角在鬧的
對啊
OK OK
原來是這樣
今年三月就開始了
不過我們上禮拜台灣不是很強
對 這很強
你可以發現新台幣也很強
我們從高到低
這反彈的幅度大概是0.7塊
會議途計的反過來看
不要以股價漲量就完蛋了
沒有 這個是好事
這個是升值才會漲這樣
沒錯 所以你可以發現
我們那一波七月的這行情
其實籌碼是真的也有滿大的狀況
因為我們一路的慢慢的是環扁的
那不過最近美元指數
A是比較疲軟的
所以我們新台幣也拉得很不錯
那當然今天就有出現了一個
值漲回貶的狀態
所以要稍微注意一下
因為外資也是結束連六賣
所以是有相關的
這裡
好
今天賣了119億
應該說結束連6買
連6買不好意思
因為8月以來真的是
買人積極在買的
難得看到
跟台幣非常的緊密結合
但只要台幣不升
那外資可能就先停
或是外資停了
台幣就不升
沒錯
所以目前看起來
但我覺得也不錯
就至少我們有升得快一快
台灣股市才有7000點的行情
好 那再來我們繼續看下來
所以籌碼我覺得
稍微震盪一下應該還可以
那再來呢
近期還是有一個主角非常不錯
就是細光子
細光子
而且他可能圍繞在世界的融資大哥
現在是輝達的身上
沒有錯
Ai融資中心
所以呢
我覺得CPO後續還是要持續關注
那當然就那幾個族群
應該大家都
沒買過應該也都知道有拿幾支了
他不要買了
我們看一下輝達宣布
這一個他的細光子交換機
要正式量產了
CPO會正式邁入大規模的商用
這個就是從實驗到驗證
到現在是要商用化
那這個大家就自己看一下
重點在這裡
大家自己看一下
重點是最近都在聊的是
真的有所謂的光通訊的需求缺口
一路缺喔
訂單已經開始往後排
沒錯 排到2027年
那預期會延續到2028年
所以還有兩年的時間
那對啦 兩年半
那當然股價會停前發酵
再來台灣供應鏈
其實它就只有
有宣布幾家公司
對 只有 因為他宣布十一家
那裡面台廠有四家
那當然這個外溢出來的
很多族群各股
大家還是可以去探討一下
台積電 紅海
月光旗下的戲品還有不若威
那這些就是從二零二五年以來
這個輝達的注資計畫
因為之前當然有研調機構
就講到輝達這樣全世界借錢
變成世界債主是對他不好的
可是事實上我覺得
這是一個滿偉大的計畫
沒錯 對
如果這些他投資的公司
能夠陸續的因為他的注資
而在新創的發展上面
對 轉虧為營的話
他就會有所謂AI新活種的加入
而且不是燒錢的新活種
所以我覺得這樣的布局是非常有意義
這是一盤大局
這個局可能要好幾年
這個視野要非常的廣
好 那我們來看視野
目前比較短一點的
就是近期走勢
我們先看小局
對對對 近期走勢
我們台灣股市今天跌了548點
是近期的一個相對比較大的點點
而且在錄影的同時
可能夜盤也是比較微弱的
對 點250點左右
那我們來看一下
大盤一路從這個39004左右
一路反彈到46004
所以反彈了7000點
那短短幾天 兩週的時間
所以有沒有一個短線
漲多的疑慮
我認為是有的
但是這個疑慮就會是說
這邊彈完了
要準備要直接這樣再下來
其實我覺得不會
要給大家一點信心
我覺得是不會
所以這一波反彈的過程中
我們很多跟著降槓槓
這個去估值啊
不不不不
大家其實心情還沒有回復
那回復到現在呢
其實大家就可以陸續續注意了
回落過程中有沒有新的買進的機會
剛剛要回復
他就直接又給你
就是攤真求證
你可能受傷兩次嘛
對啊 那接下來這一次就不要錯過了
這一次就不要錯過了
但是也不是說講話好樂觀
明天有疊就去買
我們給大家一些比較技術面上的應用
我們這邊一路沿著誰去墊高
沿著五綠軍線
所以其實是蠻強的走勢
不過今天蠻確定的是五綠軍線是跌破了
五綠軍線跌破就要注意
這一波可能就要稍微休息
震盪一下
震盪過程中我們去觀察幾個支撐區
當然軍線這邊全部都是支撐
十日軍 二十日軍
季線都是支撐
目前我比較看的是月線跟季線
如果這邊能夠出現黃金交叉
我覺得走勢未來應該非常可以期待
那另外一個這是G線給的
再來就是K棒給的
這一根大量就是這一根紅K
那這個紅K的高低點都可以視為短支撐
所以這邊大概是4萬5000點
跟這裡大概是4萬4到4萬3800左右
所以來到這個區間
我們先看4萬5000點的附近
能不能有一個漂亮的下影線
或者是說開低走高的大紅K
那如果有我覺得就視為直跌
那相對的如果沒有就直接可能
我們可能不小心就直接跌破了
那我們就回來看這個地方
然後再看有沒有出現這樣子的訊號
我都能視為這邊應該都會是一個
新的好買點
所以這邊我們稍微注意一下
讓他震盪一下短線漲多
那漲多過程中少一些紙碟的訊號
就有機會是新的進場機會
好 再來另外一個就是貴買
貴買這一波反彈
其實這一波反彈幅度也不輕
可是因為他前面跌跌比較重
那目前來說我們注意的是
他來到季線兩天沒有過
沒有過 他今天整理的幅度會比較大
我們大盤守十日軍
但櫃滿是連十日軍一起跌破了
所以今天周小谷的體感是比較差一點點
比較差一點點
那尤其這個上升趨勢
都一級頭被破壞掉了
所以我覺得櫃滿這邊
也稍微注意一下
這一個平台的位置
能不能回測完之後
有做一些防守
然後再看有沒有機會
來一個N字型的走勢區墊高
這裡就有機會是主勝段
所以我們先等止蝶
然後好的訊號出現
譬如說他止蝶就算了
還一口氣占回全部均線
那我覺得這個要過高的機會就很大
所以目前來說
大家可以這兩天去觀察一下
尤其明天要臺紫棋
因為結算 那結算完之後
而有沒有一個新的脈絡
可以去延續下一個月
那我覺得都是可以好好注意的
等於你們在看技術形態的時候
這邊來做一些整理
反而是一個比較好的
所以對頭朋友也是
因為你說你是神人嗎
可以做到這麼一大段
那很少的人
是
可是如果證明基本面
那些測試過沒有問題
那整理一下
再上就是剛剛艾倫講的主聲段
可能反而會展開
對啊 所以我覺得
你說會打第二隻腳嗎
我覺得概率偏低
你不是說每次都要畫那麼兇嗎
沒有嘛 因為概率偏低嘛
但有可能一個狀況
就長短腳
是
長短腳
不是長這樣嗎
對啊 所以我覺得不用
有回落應該是可以站在一個
開心的狀態
我們到台積電
台積電目前也滿明確的
就一個區間震盪
2,300到2,450
所以等這個高點去做突破
應該就是心動的的展開
那在台大店
我們原本一直畫的越縣
向上趨勢線
在最近上禮拜也做突破了
那不過跟上櫃一樣有點類似
就是都來到季線挑戰兩天
都有一些賣壓被賣下來了
那目前上升趨勢還在
那以台大店來講
現在800福原本說也後出貨
那現在已經要陸續出貨了
所以我覺得未來基本面
應該會反映在股價身上
那來到這個地方
我覺得台大店有點委屈
所以長先來講
台大店現在這個狀態
應該是可以縫低去 陸續做佈局的
可以拿一點信心
好 等於雙臺
還有臺光店是創歷史新高
看到臺光店創歷史新高
台積電是一個穩盤要角
而台大店是一個有點委屈的
其實我們的三臺還是蠻厲害的
所以在剛剛的大前提一下
因為這段時間只要下修
我們對於基本面產業面
都降得非常清晰了
而現在排面上
偶爾會有一些亂流
劉慮一戰
他不是一個新的消息
可是他造成了一些
在技術現行上的回檔
這回檔目前都是健康的
就等著剛剛艾倫講的
回檔修正之後
如果Y字又回頭
那主聲段可能就會展開
所以趕快回來來告訴你
到底我們看好哪一些的產業
尤其像PCB
他們在半年報上面的成績非常好
未來產業展望也很高
下半段來幫你做分享了
好 我們來分享
最近還是有一個族群
非常的深猛
是 火海鮮
好 有創歷史新高的
都蠻深猛的
是的 這個
我們今天講的是
已經成型的ABF
因為其實更深猛的
我覺得是材料
對...就是PCB最上游啦
中游那一類 CC游那一類
不過我們接下來講一下ABF
這個我們上次我還記憶猶存
怎麼樣 那個誰
婉庭經理
是總經理
總經理 不好意思
加個總 不好意思...
有來說嘛 他們有看好
明年是封裝年嘛
是 對 那確實目前看起來
陸續有一些新聞出來就是
這一些三大廠 景碩星際難電
未來的ABF的比例會拉更高
然後BT的比例會趨近於0
對 所以目前看起來ABF的缺貨狀況
應該是非常非常明確的
那這個當然就是前四家嘛
台灣可能以跟ABF比較明確的
不過我們今天要講的是這三家
我們剛剛有提到有一些外溢的效應
對 像今天星星總算創一個歷史新高了
新興創歷史新高喔
對 南電跟緊受在前面
那個股災之前就已經創歷史新高
不知道哪裡去了
所以我們剩下輪流啊現在
對 以星星的角度來講
他就是在南電這個位置
對 那南電這一波拉很兇嘛
那個時候星星一下發債啊
一下要幹嘛呢
股價就卡在那邊
其實之前都有分享過
是 星星這個有過高了
好 如也7月21號來看
那時候星星其實相較之下
就是比較便宜的
我們一直講說他是第一大廠
應該要跟上
結果這一波反彈
他倒是率先創歷史新高
對 發拍手
沒錯喔 這是星星
不負重望 中語啊
但也因為他這個前高都比較低
因為緊縮
什麼前高比較低
緊縮有創高
緊縮這個星星沒高
所以有創高
南殿這裡也有創高
那我們來看一下
要跟大家講的是後面這幾位
好
這個金像殿
因為延續剛剛的例子
對不對
曾經落後的現在都長回來了
這個也是長服落後的
是啊
金像殿你看
他現在才要挑戰季線
反而高在這
對 有點
而且他這波疊的
其實很重
這個是7月嘛
人家6月中就開始
6月就開始跌了
對 零跌
那後面也撐不住
那目前來說
EPS看31到38塊
目標價有喊到1700的天價
因為PCB的
本EPS會給的稍微
比較樂觀一點點
那不管怎麼樣
金像電現在的股價來講
我個人認為就是稍微委屈一點點
那以剛剛我們看景碩行業難電
他們都是在這個附近
或者是已經突破這個高點了
那你回來看金像天
哎呀 這個機器是真的有在低
我那下鄉區市線也做突破了
沿著越線 前面就做突破了
那今天盤中有漲停
不過大盤不太好
所以有被壓抑一點點
當然是漲6%
那漲6%也做了這一個小平台的突破
那蠻明確的
這裡應該是一個N字型的確立了
所以接下來季線只要站上
基本上就是全部均線站回
然後N字型的一個多方結構
去向上做延伸
今天也有出一點量
所以我覺得呢
應該都可以好好注意一下
假設你緊縮信息難電
第一選擇一定是他們
但是如果你覺得現在他們有點貴
那我覺得落後補漲的應該都有一些機會
這個是金像電的部分
好 這裡是非常多網友在問的
營收的數字都開得非常漂亮
是 那可是股價卻腰斬
前面一陣子是腰斬的
再來看到的就是滑通
哇 這個他的線怎麼啦
他要怎麼躺著橫線啊
哇 誰這個線畫得好直啊
華通其實在今年上半年
可能還在100塊
那也有長到300多塊
其實他們漲幅也已經非常兇了
那最近又回到這個地方
其實股價也一度來到154塊
也是接近搖展
那搖展到過程中
大家前面注意
大家一起漲的時候
他有跟著拉
但是這一波大盤
上週開始再繼續創高的時候
華通就沒有跟上了
那沒有跟上
我們這邊就可以稍微注意一下
跟金像電視一樣的邏輯
就是這基本面也OK
然後有各自也題材
就是低軌衛星等等的 量產等等的
那接下來如果要做一個資金的輪動
會不會高階的
股價已經偏高了 在上面做震盪
然後資金往外溢到一些低位階的族群
其實我現在有的人在看這樣子
就是找一些低位階來做
那華藤目前來說
我們可以注意到這裡拉上來
在這邊做震盪 然後呢 都是量縮
今天也量縮
今天其實大盤長500 跌500點嘛
他沒有跌
他很奇妙他守在他的憲增加
做橫盤整理 我也不懂
就是他是怕上去會有人認憲增加
馬上要賣掉嗎 還是怎麼樣
感覺從頭到尾都不錯
我只能這樣說
因為你上禮拜長 他也沒長
這禮拜疊了 他也不疊
就在這邊鎮
所以我覺得他就是等一個發動的契機
那只要這個平台低點都有收好
那就是看哪時候會帶量
突然像這樣子
突然出一個量 轟K拉出去
那基本上應該行情就會有一個
新的走勢可以去推伸
那目前來說
我覺得進場的停順點非常好抓
要嘛平台做跌破
要嘛你覺得基本面真的很好
那我手前低
可是前低可能有點遠
所以可以大家看自己的操作邏輯
去做停順的佈局
那佈局完之後就等發酵了
因為我覺得接下來大盤
要進入正當過程
應該還是會有族群充滿做表現
對 因為可能就是懸鼓不選刺
那開始找一些地位接又基本面不錯的
那或許後面會有一些機會
再來看就是見頂
好公司
其實他這波談有算是有像樣談
是的
那個時候他就是率先去反映外裔的訂單
連續兩根掌停單
是的
來到這個地方也出現了一個
比較型態
他比那個
金像墊跟華通來的強
因為他這邊是站上季線的
華通跟金像墊都是準備挑戰季線
所以型態來講
見頂稍微比較強
但相對的就是他可能這裡也長得
比較多一點點
那多一點點可以注意到這裡出現了一個
高檔爆大量
所以呢
這裡就會是一個觀察的壓力區
如果這邊能夠做突破
那這個行情應該就是
換手成功準備挑戰前高
那再來另外一個
他這邊高檔爆大量之後呢
股價也沒有直接向下重挫
而是守住這個缺口的
高點位置在這邊做橫盤正當
所以我覺得他整理方式應該也偏強
那剩下的就是看
你什麼時候來一個更明確的換手
再去做一個N字型的突破去追價
那或者說要不然就跌升一點
跌升一點
那看有沒有一些
又是一些價值的地方出現
再來重新去做介入
所以這三個都會是PCB
剛剛都是
因為其實大家比較鎖定的還是ABF
或者是材料
反而是中間這些HDI
或者說BT系列
或者說其他的
伺服器板材
沒錯 都是大家沒有這麼著墨
其實還有很多
什麼男子店 電影頭控
高級 他們的位階都蠻低的
但是就沒有亮
沒有亮那就沒有價
那目前來說有一些相關的
可能更機油一點
或者說比較紮實一點的
開始在陸續做一些小反應
那我覺得是可以去注意一下
有沒有落後補償的機會
因為這組群很大
很大
那現在竟然載板類、ABF類的
已經往上衝了
它就開始陸續帶動
可能跟AI的收費程度
也有一定程度的落差
我覺得是這樣
但是如果等量能回來
或是像剛剛我們形容的台幣
如果繼續做一個
升值外資營運回來的話
那整體PTP其實在
繳出的產業獲利上面是非常好的
是的
那同樣的如果需要今天節目
所有的圖卡資料
歡迎訂閱一下我們的趙華艾倫說
目前是三萬YouTuber
不是百萬YouTuber
還需要大家的幫忙